birth control pills or something
you know you can't get pregnant from
yeah I got a lot of holes in my house
right now
[Music]
six one foreign
y'all doing good today
what's the owner of this car man
you're welcome
okay you got your idea on you man
y'all doing all right today
so the reason I pulled yours because
your tag okay I can't I can't see your
attack 50 feet from the rear which in
the state of Georgia did you
from where who took it from you before
I know that
foreign
I'll be right back let me check things
out okay
783 westjeta out there
um no I got a lot of cash in 30.
[Music]
um okay I smell my wall right here yeah
they're they're from the party
um
I think we should move it over there
because we're about to get deep into
here
hey step out for me real quick
it's gonna be entertained for now good
all right
all right real quick
all right there's any weapons on you
knives guns drugs
all right so you need marijuana
so I'm getting the strong odor of it
stay back
all right is there any marijuana
yeah
okay so you're good I got you as long as
you're honest with me almost with you
okay
[Music]
all right
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
what's the news
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
well he claims she's a restaurant
I'm tired bro I'm tired
I'm gonna make you charge me
because I'm tired bro
I'm tired bro
punch on the first White Boy
[Applause]
what's up
I'm ready
where I'm from
pulling me up I got 39. I don't give a
fuck
I don't give up
I moved out here
[Music]
[Music]
they can take me right now I would give
them
I'm tired bro
I'm tired bro
nigga
everybody
I'm getting targeted bro my license
plate is white I'm targeting
your knife
all right
um
foreign
foreign
okay
[Music]
I've got like ten thousand dollars in
there too shit
I know exactly how much I got don't
worry
That's My Boy money
and I got receipts for it I just left
the bank I got another cashier's
checking the side that door there's a
cashier checking the side that you know
also for a large amount of money please
don't
right now I swear to God
let's roll right
be away
I'm tired
[Music]
hard time stolen registration is right
the tag is right
targeting my vehicle
you're targeting my vehicle
if I was a white college player you in
with my vehicle if I play soccer or
baseball you win for my vehicle you'll
stop us for autographs
[Music]
seven stops in two weeks how can I live
I ain't got nothing but just that little
bit that we come
[Music]
reality that's
I
mean
it's not big enough for me
it's no ticket you didn't speed you
didn't do anything there's no tickets
they couldn't see you license plate
there's no ticket bro
please
so what would you what did you establish
I stopped you for the tag what's wrong
with attack it says 705 correct but you
can't see the letters 50 feet
you see the numbers
so this was that's what I'm gonna do
that's a license plate
all right
I'm gonna give you the citation
for marijuana
all right for the smell of marijuana
yeah
all right let me give you
um
and that's it all right I'm gonna let
y'all be on busted
are we good yeah okay we'll take the
handcuffs off we're gonna sit in the car
foreign
the volts under your seat real quick
so don't stand the Trap don't stand
traffic
all right all your cash and everything
is in the center board okay you can have
this there's really not much in there
okay
this this five dollars was in your bag
all right
hey man have a seat for me and I'll be
right with you okay
foreign
[Music]
charge okay
so it's not easy
so this is this is what I found in here
okay
okay
um who's gonna take the
gonna take both of them okay all right
[Music]
hey you have a background for the truck
or do you know where it's at
I need my fucking paperwork for my
fucking truck
oh my God
okay no problem
I don't
give a fuck
I need to get them
thank you
um I'm gonna open your door real quick
and get your PIN okay
[Music]
what year is this this is 1022. okay
I'm almost done I just gotta do
um
[Music]
all right back
is business manager I have the
dealership on the line
paper a problem with this paperwork
there is but we got it all figured out
so you good
um but he does need to get yeah
[Music]
you're all right
[Music]